the only thing that lets us know if an  idea is good is if we keep thinking  about it for a long time like we come up  with you know five times a week one of  us will turn in the other and be like  you know make a funny movie this like oh  this would make a funny movie idea oh  maybe we should make a movie about this  the ones that become movies are the ones  where three years later we're still  being like Oh and then you know what  else is gonna happen in that movie like  they start out as lists of just ideas  watching with something like this at the  end like it was just  first it was like we like this idea of  like people playing themselves in a i in  a world that was Supernatural that was  funny to us